big thanks to our sponsor betterhelp
easy and affordable online therapy get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday that's
better
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday for a 10
off we're so excited about our new
sponsor Sakara you guys they're
nutritionally designed Chef crafted
breakfasts lunches and dinners are made
with powerful plant-rich ingredients and
Sakara is offering our listeners 20 off
their first order when they go to
sakara.com trash Tuesday or enter code
trash Tuesday at checkout hi you guys
I'm back on the road and I'm going to be
in DC Austin and other places you can
get tickets at estheronice.com well
howdy who Austin Texas I'm coming
straight to you to the Vulcan gas
company on July 29th two shows one night
only get your mother effing tickets
before they sell out you see how I
caught myself
see how I caught myself and that's what
you're gonna see on the show just me
catching myself no it's going to be the
best get your tickets it's going to be
so fun I can't wait to come to Austin
you can then see me after that I'll be
in Springfield Missouri I'll be in
Pittsburgh I'll be in Tempe I'll be at
the coluso casino in Colusa California
I'll be in Kansas City Missouri I'll be
in Irvine San Jose Michigan and Florida
go to annieleterman.com shows to get
tickets
[Music]
thank you
are you a Shopaholic like Annie are you
a Shopaholic that's such a fun question
do you love shopping I like it's very
new to me like what you're talking about
how I look oh this is you caring yeah no
I just gotta get it I gotta get a level
all it took was 5 000 YouTube comments
no you I think your look is so cute this
is so much carrying her even like a year
ago Annie had the famous thing which you
always said that when I did my sets at
The Comedy Store it looked like I had
just gotten out of bed like that sounds
so much nice for them when I said
there's no way yeah you know know what
you look like
I told you look like an abort or a
miscarried fetus oh that was recently
yeah that's all my fashion though that's
my my aura
okay so a little background on Esther's
Esther has um many family members that
were supposed to be aborted oh what
supposed to be aborted like how do you
you have two like your mom just goes
around you're not supposed to be here no
they're like there's just there's a lot
of like early young pregnancies I'm half
very white trash so like people just get
I think you're all or none I don't know
I don't know if white trash I think it
literally kills whatever else is in
there Jewish Jewish if you're white
trash it will destroy your jewishness it
will bring you down
please I I try to crawl out of white
trashness my whole life I said my
husband is like
so consumed with being white trash it
says every move in life you know and I'm
always like we're we gotta get out of
this her husband has been chewing
Nicorette for 16 years yeah yeah like
that's pretty garbage yeah it's like not
supposed to go that way no you're
supposed to right yeah from what I
assume yeah so you're married to a
stand-up comedian yes you are both
stand-up comedians yes we're better than
you sorry it is just it is what it is no
Esther one smart Esther got engaged to a
writer accommoderator but he doesn't
he's not a fan of hers
she got like she gets like one-liners
here and there oh my God but she really
had an angle she really had I really
tried no I my thing was like I don't
wanna I was not attracted to men that
wanted to be on camera but I wanted
someone that was like would still
understand right well yeah I think
that's right so writer was like the
target the lowest thing you could go she
no she went pretty low
well Bonnie was the one I went to the
independent Spirit Awards oh my God
after party she goes I go before her I
got there before her they were still
like finishing up no can I just do it a
little bit okay so I was the head writer
of the independence
so I thought we I was a total in for the
party I called somebody and they were
like I don't know if we can get you on I
was like what I wrote it you know yeah
and then uh he was like well say you're
a writer so then I caught you know just
say you're a writer when you get to the
door and then I told Annie to say she
was a writer which in looking back is so
funny that I would make her have to say
something so horrific
to get into a party if they would give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] about the right see I had
no idea I was still like living this
belief that I was important in some way
to that she also dressed like a writer
like she had like a b and we had to work
that day she had like two backpacks on
when she went to the party there is
actually something I'm very curious to
ask you about which is is that you are
one of the rare people in Showbiz who's
in like a video possibly becoming a very
long term successful relationship well I
don't know about successful but yeah
we're hanging in there we got separate
bedrooms things is that true yes isn't
that amazing yeah and but it is a life
changer I still have to [ __ ] them
to your room to get [ __ ] or do you go
to heaven I go to his room and then um
so you know what's gonna happen when you
go to his room it's like yeah that's
right that's where the lube is if you're
at a festival and you go to a man's room
you know what's going to happen yes yeah
well well I got drunk the other night
and um we went back to the hotel and I
was you know trying I was like oh God
let me give you a [ __ ]
these knees haven't seen them
comedy in a while and uh it was outside
on the sidewalk yeah it was before they
got back I can only do whatever people
are watching
um
but uh no he was like no go to bed are
you serious well he's Richard's silver
so he was like he's gross my drunk wife
yes how dare you she was very flirty
though whoa she was drunk she was drunk
she was like when I get drunk actually
so embarrassing did you see anyone you
banged back in the day at The Comedy
Store I mean there's been so many did
you date other Comics besides Rich yes I
only dated con I just don't understand
dating outside of your field
that's like yeah yeah like what are you
gonna talk about you can talk about your
own set and then your husband is in
sleep apnea and you're gonna just talk
about that all the time well you would
like that okay
my husband sells the machines so when
you're on a plate she was telling me how
to play and she I died I can diagnose
people on planes if they're have sleep
apnea I do it without autism
I was doing it last night you're like I
noticed you weren't looking me in the
eye I go you're looking like a little
past me shifty-eyed yeah this kid has
autism and it's I look everyone's on
their Journey but I'm like I could save
you a little time I
I'm not breaking HIPAA violations here
I'm just letting you know that if you
were to go get tested they will tell you
ding ding ding you're on the Spectrum
but by that point I mean that guy had to
have already he had to go to a special
school he's he can't be in regular no no
it was like special school but we had
fun bullying him and um you know this is
the thing about bullying I feel like
honestly
people you never you never get that like
the opposite side like the feel goodness
of being a bully you know what I mean
like I left there with a little bounce
in my step honestly I identify as a
bully and I feel like we're being yeah
discriminated we're being silenced
interesting I I don't have much to add
to that you better not so much to add a
bully Oscar don't ever say that don't
ever sell yourself don't ever tell
yourself
sorry no Esther's the best to be bullied
I do I do appreciate because it's like
not bullied but I think like a playful
yes a playfulness oh wait I have to show
you guys so I have
I'm doing my set in Texas I have my show
on the 29th so I'm pandering to the
Texas audience so everyone comes to the
Vault mailing it on the 29th do you
start by singing the Star Spangled
Banner I do I I get my gun out I shoot a
fetus oh no wait you want them to live I
shoot a doctor I shoot a doctor who's
trying to kill the fetus yes
I saved the fetus with prayer and then
um but okay so I got more but you know
the gun that I want to use to Pander I
brought here
oh my God oh my God I filled it with
oatmeal oh please do not I'm a vegan I
filled it with oat milk I'm a little
tempted she's thirsty I'm okay on this
please Don't Spray me I'm not gonna
spray you but if you open your mouth I
will give you a little lick I'll give
you a little drippy it's so funny
because everyone this is chlamydia every
once in a while like Dave will be uh
what's it called watering plants and I
won't spray you you're so scared is that
what people call it and he'll be like
what would happen if I just sprayed
because everyone a divorce a divorce a
divorce like Dave when Dave sprays you
it's because he's trying to get you to
break up with him
that's a good thing I should be we're
all there with you we're all for some
reason like why is everyone here
you look like come like on the table
there's like two triplets wait will you
drink some
yeah come here Carlos Carlos how bad do
you want to be a part of this goddamn
show I'm on the show I'm on the show
that's what I'm saying how bad do you
want to be a part of it you could very
easily not be on it
down down is this Gonna Get Us
demonetized duh wait hold on I'm wearing
the salines
[Laughter]
it's like the least good thing you've
done honestly but I'm so sorry to tell
you I'm diagnosing you with uh autism
G what wait what is happening
I like that it's oh God I got his eye
I want to try to get me in the mouth I
did but I'm not facing you it's hard
you gotta buy another one you rich piece
of [ __ ] Carlos's parents are rich
oh Bonnie is down it's oat milk because
I can't do it with real I'm a vegan so
can you not deal with coffee yeah no I
won't do it I'm trying to save the
planet you know let's just say I'm not a
vegan
[Laughter]
I like to keep my children inside me yes
yes why does the oatmeal taste like the
full cereal it tastes like a full cereal
it's got sugar in it yeah
it has sugar in it I kill myself what
Carlos killed you Carlos there's sugar
in that there's also a gun next to you
to a gun lighter I know I love the gun
later I always forget about it yeah
do you know what oat milk is
kids this is circle time
um no hats are so annoying wait I want
Circle time I was do you know I was a
nursery school teacher I wait what job
have you not done no I do sound like a
pathological liar because because you're
a pathological liar that's the only
thing you've ever done
I said it Bonnie and I had a weird week
of our friendship tell me everything I
didn't say in anger I said it with like
respect I was like you're gonna make it
because you're a social man and I went
I just want to say I was sentenced but
the gun gun is better than the penis
three women were just censored by two
one and a Half Men okay
they are not letting me have my weapon
my self-defense weapon but if you say
I'm gay then you're saying gay people
are Half Men I never said you were a guy
okay I just said maybe you should
consider it being gay
you're born that way well you know
what's crazy is when I was little my dad
sat me and my sister down at the time
started making out with a guy
he just started tonging down a dude it
was so weird I said don't worry it's oat
milk
he literally was like I would like both
of you to cons to seriously consider
lesbianism with each other no no sorry
kaleila's not here I just wanted to
bring a little collage
[Laughter]
no but now I look back and I'm like what
was that moment was it a joke was it a
tease of me because they used to make
fun of me that I would download naked
pictures of girls like I don't know what
that really was about why would he
didn't know about that no they did they
all knew behind my back but then why was
he telling you to try lesbianism that's
what everybody were trying that's what I
was figuring out right in my as live
you've been trying lesbianism for a long
time
to the point where it goes it's not
really the trial thing yeah it's like
let's get rid of this guy why is there
this guy here there's just this pesky
man in your life yeah because there's
the the right like you're basically just
you're it's not that you're straight
you're just still like to have the
Patriotic approve you yeah yes I want to
be oh she wants to eat [ __ ] but she
wants guys to want to eat her [ __ ] yes
yes that's the dream guys we figured it
out that's our new name we eat [ __ ] but
we want you to eat our want to eat our
[ __ ] it's like a little the podcast
very short maybe it's such a good name
now are we getting bloodbath back Annie
I have a really important question
um I I got a DM from uh Nicole the poll
who I told you guys about Oh Nicole the
poll is uh pull I want to call an artist
she's a poll artist okay okay
her shoulders are bigger I was thinking
like polish yeah she's a Polish you are
white trash
a lot no sausages she thought I was
about to do like a joke about how I
don't know how to tie their shoes or
something we but wait Bonnie where did
you grow up Alberta Canada what yeah the
farm girl yeah
um I have a book it's called you're
better than me and you can find out all
about my childhood really yes Esther
will read it I can I will no I'm like
she's a fan girl I have like a thing
with female comedians like I get like do
you see how her anchor you want us to
want to eat your [ __ ] her heel is like
in her vagina you see that
oh look
I'm also the girl right below it but um
look at that what's that what the hell
is that why did that show up for yours
Ah that's me I don't know
oh my God I do want to know more about
like sustaining a long-term relationship
because I feel like you know what it is
it's just don't break up right it's
literally accept everything you know the
thing is like obviously rich is one of
the most annoying people on the planet
yeah and but he's not a compulsive
Gambler he says he's not drugs he's not
like do you know what I mean like it's
like faster
it's like there's certain things that
would throw you off the path yes right
that's true like drug addict alcoholic
it's like but what is your advice for
not getting broken up with oh I don't
know I mean I just married someone who
could never do any better so that's what
Esther did
Esther's whole stand-up special was
about that pretty much was it really I
don't even remember a lot of it was like
you would see Dave like laughing but
also kind of like
oh but I do think that's good advice to
go for someone who you know can't do
better than you well I think like most
guys get there anyway because I think
honestly most guys are codependent so
unless they meet someone else you're
kind of good
do you know what I mean like they'll
leave you for someone else I will tell
you though even though we think we're
finding people that can't do better than
us when you do release the guy that you
pulled up yeah and brought up to your
level girls saw you with him and then
they start getting a caliber of girls
that was never in their realm of
possibility right and they might not be
better than you if you have the right
self-esteem no one's is better than you
right but
but they can get pretty close like
they're not going back to what they were
dating before you that's interesting
like is that almost like Pete Davidson
dating Ariana Grande yes yes
right but no I think it was um first he
dated
um what's the woman Matt Rife dated to
uh Kate back in seconds was that before
Ariana yeah no way no yeah and then
before that it was Larry David's
daughter oh it was after never mind oh
yeah she's cute too yeah so that's like
yeah that's an interesting Theory I
heard he's been eyeing up Oprah
you've texted me about a friend of mine
once
he texted me about a friend of mine and
he was like oh and I knew because he had
is it Harley asked me Carly called me
and was like that's hard to say she's
married rich Voss I go she's listen
she's not quitting she said one thing
about her relationship she's not gonna
break up
Annie you were right Cassie David came
before Ariana Grande wait it was Cassie
but what about Kate Beckinsale that's
after Ariana
there's back in sale who's he gonna go
to after Kim there's nowhere to go after
Kim that's what I'm saying except for
Kylie
right yeah yeah Kylie would make more
sense than Kim to me well age-wise he
dated this girl you know I so I
obviously sorry I worshiped Kim
Kardashian like in my private time
please let respect my privacy
[Music]
like please I don't bring that here but
just uh you bring it here so much she's
always like do you know what I saw on
Tick Tock Kim Kardashian that's always
the sentence but like so it's hard for
me when I see the picture she's posting
of her and Pete I'm like
I when I met when we all met Pete he was
a child he was so I see him as a little
boy and I'm like what am I looking at
this is so weird this is like when I go
back to visit Todd's family and his mom
tries to show me like pictures of him
from like four years
renting cars he loved these pajamas I
was renting cars and living in the
rental car while this boy was getting
his first bike it's like
I do have that experience with people I
follow on like cool girls I follow on
Tick Tock where I'm like oh these are
like my peers and then like they so this
is me three years ago and they're little
kids this is weird am I
going to jail you look little so you can
sneak in thank you oh my God we should
do a okay I already wanna I'm putting
this out into the universe if there's
any comedy writers that want to like
that like writing things that wanna like
take anything well I think we should do
twins remake yes okay we're she's on can
I see you guys standing next to each
other I just want to see the poster
oh my God
I love it I love it
pretty girl privilege like it is so a
crazy thing that you have and I also
look like all of the popular boys in
middle school so I had like Silver Chair
privilege but it's almost like you made
yourself like the way you behave to like
you want it to equal the playing field
yeah
well my brother was slower than me you
know
no um I looked like [ __ ] and you know
you don't grow into your although I saw
you on FaceTime last week without makeup
and I was like
she's pretty stunning without makeup
were you masturbating I just I really
thought a joke was coming I was like yes
the people that are still expecting a
joke
really like set a thing up and then
she'll look at me and I'm like that's
right girl I love that
teachers like and then you even did like
the little smile like oh it's gonna be
bad you're like you're hot and this is
when she figured out she was a squirter
how do you have like sex advice like for
I feel like I've been wanting a
dictionary long-term relationships but
then literally kalila and Bobby broke up
so I'm like now we have I have something
yeah absolutely ask me anything well can
give us advice on long-term
relationships that's true at 10 years
dip
say would say
kalila right now is going with Bobby to
get ketamine treatment
oh right now that's where she is yeah
right now kalia's in a k-hole she's like
is this me or the clouds do you think
she's thinking of us
listen Esther it's not a good thing if
she's thinking it's really bad Bonnie
better not be in my chair
[Music]
now a word from our sponsor better help
you guys
um mental health has been a a big theme
in this podcast because we are not
immune to
um days of feeling down days of feeling
anxious well no I say one time I I
facetimed kalila and she just said we're
all just broken people trying to keep it
together and we are and we are well I
have a question how well would you take
care of your car if it was the only one
you had your whole life
and that is weird coming for me because
I have only had one car in my whole life
and you did not take good care of it
even a little bit but your brain is you
have just one the whole time you're here
and you should take care of it and you
can by using better help better health
is easy and affordable online therapy I
swear by therapy it has been an
indispensable part of my life they have
this really cool Journal feature where I
get to write down my thoughts during the
week in between therapy sessions you can
start talking to a counselor in just
under 48 hours and if it's not a match
you can switch to another counselor it's
also much more affordable than in-person
traditional therapy and if you're not in
the mood that week to speak to someone
on video you have the option for just a
phone call and also just how fast you
can do it is so important because I feel
like I'm one of these people this is one
of the things I do work on in therapy is
when there's something I need to do that
I know is going to be good for me my ego
fights it so much and I distract myself
so if there's one thing like oh I don't
know where I'm going to park when I go
to this office I will just not do the
whole thing so the fact that butter help
makes it so easy and it just kind of
packaged together for you and you can
just do it all from your own home is
just key and it's like one small step
towards the bigger goal of improving
your life and our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhealth.com
trash Tuesday that's better
h-e-l-p.com trash Tuesday
[Music]
do you guys ever engage or dabble in
like role play or like
spicing things up well we have
definitely tried but he's
um he's incorrigible no
we just it's becomes too laughy yeah
okay you're both too silly yeah yeah I
mean he's ridiculous
when you guys have sex I mean I
sometimes have to remind him to take it
out I swear to God because I don't know
if you know this but we eat two
Nicorette they put it in their top lip
they just leave it there
so they can I don't know why that get
more of the they're not just chewing it
all the time they're just letting it
seep out through the top of as soon as
he forgets it's there
and then I'm like what is why is my
[ __ ] stuck together yeah you're like
why is that actually happened to me my
ex-boyfriend was chewing big red stop I
swear in my life he was chewing big red
that's what she calls her [ __ ]
what the rest of the time I just call it
big
but after the character big because yes
you know sometimes it
no no no not from the show big that's so
funny
as from the movie Big it's it's named
after Tom hanks's character because
I like to think it's in a child's body
doesn't have hair yeah I never grew hair
okay I have another question because you
have a child yeah which is like oh [ __ ]
huge deal she's a mama oh yeah you're
not a mom like I'm kidding I didn't even
know that what until a couple weeks ago
you brought that up well I just saw one
I never heard that term I don't want to
be judgy because everyone picks their
path and everything but there were these
comedians that were coming after this
used to happen all the time at the
comedy store they would post like the
lineup and then these like you know
usually there were like older female
comedians that weren't like I've never
met they haven't been around in a while
right well oh were they taking care of
their children they're probably taken
care of maybe your children I've never
seen you with your daughter
um you seem to make it well I just don't
have one I just never seen you with her
well we can tell you have a kid because
you're wearing her clothes but
um she would cry if she heard you say
that it should be like I would never her
daughter's gonna do like uh like [ __ ]
clothes wait really yeah well and she's
either wearing like an oversized t-shirt
where it looks like she's not wearing
any pants I'm always like can you just
like tuck it in a little on the sides
she goes people know I'm wearing shorts
under here but it does seem like we're
conversation with Dave like like it
looks like you're not it looks like a
mistake you're like I'm sorry I got a
toddler too I thought it would be short
enough to see my shorts
now okay so last week on our episode we
decided that we were gonna have
self-worth summer yeah we all need to
like build up our self-worth and I feel
like since you have a child who's like
in entering like [ __ ] clothing yeah
it's like how would you advise maybe two
other young ladies [ __ ] clothed girls
to have like self-worth like do you have
any how do you build up software well I
first of all my daughter is 14. her only
fans is off the chain so she's getting a
lot of
Financial uh you're her Kris Jenner dude
yes have you got the sex tape ready yeah
yeah yeah for that the moment you have
your own countdown oh she's gonna have a
baby I mean it's gonna be a whole thing
this is the thing is like I used to take
her with me so
like having a child is not as hard as
people make it I love it
shut up I mean I do think people try to
oh my God like I did you know you
there's times where you can't sleep as
much and obviously you know but we used
to lay in bed together and drink coffee
when she was little like it's not like
you would give her coffee
I mean I didn't are you a bad mom or a
good man no I'm a good mom she was a
great copy I was trying to think of a
joke but
um she doesn't it yeah no it [ __ ] her
heroine but it um no she is like super
cool super fun I when she was a baby I
went like this I swear to God I was like
to that was like please give me a 10 P.M
to 10 a.m baby and then she just started
going to bed at 10 p.m and waking up at
10 A.M and then people would be livid
like when they found out well I remember
uh somebody came over and I was up and
Raina was still sleeping she was like
get that baby up she's like I thought it
like rain was dead or something
but then at the parks and stuff you'd
have to people be like well time for
lunch and I'd be like oh yeah us too you
know meanwhile it was breakfast just had
breakfast yeah it's like
you do have to lie a lot as a parent
that's that's the other thing do you
feel like he's like a lot of lying I
mean it's like because there's like I
just don't engage that much in a lot of
the like Mom [ __ ] that goes on
um I don't like her getting her period
and stuff you just like she is friends
with um someone who has two moms both
gynecologists and I every day I go I
hope you get it at their house
let them show you how to put a tampon in
you should like put blood in her
underwear before she goes over
this is like we you're the mom we need
to hear from like this is so exciting
Esther I'm gonna tell you something
guess what I talk to every day her yeah
inspiration wow guess what else she does
I'm outing you what
guess what else she does hi Mary Lou
Rodriguez hypnotism she does hypnotism I
don't I don't care what she's doing
I started doing hypnosis years and years
and years and years ago she started
actually I forgot to say Bonnie started
hypnosis wait so what is your experience
with it it's just it's a magic pill why
can you like I don't know it just like I
I re years and years ago I would switch
I was living in Los Angeles now come and
stay at this guy's place in New York and
he would stay at my place in in L.A and
I would read all his books and he had
all these books on hypnosis for some
reason and so
um no did you ever use one of those
things as a Yoni egg
I don't know what you're talking one of
the like you're getting sleepy oh yeah I
don't know if there's a pendulum no um
squeezed it yes of course okay she
didn't and um yes yes I've only kegeld
twice but that was one of the times
um
so then I just started doing it and it
was it's literally like magic it's like
a weird thing that happens
and this one had all diff like this was
the the hypnosis I first started doing
was way different than the hypnosis that
I do now but it was like
I don't know you just put in to your
head so it would say like like one of
the things was like and you imagine
there you have a big pot your head is a
big pot and you put in the stuff that
you want like confidence and I stir it
around see the words going in you know
it was like this whole thing and then um
I don't know it just worked I like that
the guy like what did he learn when he
stayed in your house no I know he was
like had a garden like what [ __ ]
books did you have I had a garden in 20
minutes got a garden with a kid in your
arms what's interesting to me is that
sounds very similar to an exercise I did
in therapy like that I never would have
considered hypnosis or called it
hypnosis but it's like no that wasn't
therapy when the witch told you to get
in the pot
did you turn me into a rat just for the
weekend
um I would love to be a rat for a
weekend I don't know why uh well we
you've been making a play for that for a
while the not showering the greasy hair
it really was so fun to be a little rat
in a box and like you take me home like
I I feel like I would be this would be
easily done this is very easily done
this is a fantasy many people have
already thought of I'll poke all even
poke holes in the Box okay are you gonna
wear one of those furries
I would yeah no shower your bush who
doesn't need it I got a wax yesterday
can I see yeah she has like it looks
like there should be a penis I was
thinking Bonnie and I don't do this that
like because I have to see it because I
have we do like a podcast with girl talk
like now all these people know my wax
schedule of when I'm hearing when I'm
not what once every 10 years
oh you got it all waxed off yeah I only
get it all do you ever let me see the
bottom part
It Wide Open let me see it
I want to see what it looks like for
myself with similar hey let me let me
let's warm up with that Bonnie and I
don't show each other vaginas or
anything we've not been that type of
friends oh that's like day one like yeah
I like a little distance in my
friendships
sorry
and a little cold
because I can get leaves some if you I
yeah I usually live a Dorito
speaking of rats uh I have one in my
underwear eating the chip
I did the wax they call it um twata
tattooey
the wax was good so last minute yeah it
was so painful no one wants to hear how
painful it was it was so painful I was
sweating and afterwards I realized I
think I'm addicted to getting bikini
waxes because I get high after yes yes
that's why people get addicted to
tattoos too like the pain then you get
like your dopamine
you're scared of it yes look at her
handshake this is so real look at her
hands they're quivering
are you scared because it's a p it was a
vagina would you be into it
um no no this stance is so you can
spring out of the chair why why did you
change
when people are pointing things at
squirt at me like I get very
uncomfortable like I can't podcast I
can't do anything is Dave usually trying
to podcast me does it it's like he's
like are we rolling okay
he's like oh we're doing the ads
the mid-roll okay
but wait so people this is I literally I
feel like I got a free high like I got
high without having to do weed I was so
high from the intense pain what other
things is that why eating hot chips
Peppers eating bugs all the you face
your fears just like feel like I just
figured you out like I understand yes
that's all I do is I put myself in
painful weird situations so afterwards I
can go ah so after you eat a bug you
feel like a high wait why are you eating
bugs yeah something I don't know yeah on
this show are you trying to mirror her I
want to do it too
her and kalila will eat like and they'll
eat anything oh yeah it's I know but
you're vegan right no I was oh my God
how could someone be a vegan and then go
back that's what she wasn't she was a
fight again she was a Netflix vegan she
saw one documentary she tried to be cool
some pretty girl told her she was a
vegan okay I was V that this is good
that is ultra pretty girl Esther and I
used to follow pretty girls around the
grocery store to see what was in their
cart and then ask them what they did one
woman took us into our apartment and
showed us all this food no no in her
fridge yeah and what was it vegan food
it was weird
but she had a lot of like she was she
was self Botox yeah oh God she also
ended up being her boyfriend's nurse and
this woman was like
I'll just say a big titted woman she had
big fake tits I was like you're his this
is tattoos he sees everything like that
he's body shaming right there
I'm sorry she showed us her fake tits
like immediately they were great
I love her I know we gotta get kaleila
to get fake tits again
we need tits in the crew wait she hates
fate tick she had them and got them
taken out oh um
it is weird yeah what was it like to
grow up as a boy I grew up uh I did want
to be a boy I wouldn't wear shirts
really you know that about nobody
noticed uh either I would only have
really short hair and I remember like
playing with these in this my my mom was
a teacher so we went to the school
during summer and then there was these
kids out there playing and then I was
playing with them and then all day we
played and then when we went inside I
went to go in the girl's bathroom
they're like that's the girl
the girls and I was like oh
I am no they used to think I was a boy
all the time yeah really yeah it's
because I just identified with my father
I think who had the power in the family
you know it still does so then I was
like
I definitely was against I was very
resistant against like all girly things
like my mom always want to put me in a
dress I would never allow it but do you
think if she didn't want you in a dress
you would have liked dresses I think
that's totally possible yeah yeah
because I do like them now like for the
first time I'm like Oh I wanna we like
you and them too thank you oh my God
like sometimes when Dave sees me in a
dress he like almost will tear up he's
like it's like such a big deal to him I
still had a glow up let me tell you
sometimes I look at our old episodes
together I go because I was always
dressing up
style but it was different no we had a
glow up but we all had a glow up but I
at least was putting on like a car I was
always wearing like a costume that's
true you would come in like I it's like
a potato rolled into my house and I put
it on my show yeah
it's weird like I did not care about how
I presented myself until like three
weeks ago like there's something
something and she would always
shoot the podcast now I'm like I have to
do at least 20 minutes yeah and I would
be like what are you talking about I'm
like be camera ready [ __ ] I couldn't
believe it I was like just be camera I
remember put your glasses on at least
Bonnie looked like [ __ ] this morning do
I shy you should do for a little bit
beautiful you wanna do both oh my God
you're hot she's so hot
gosh she's hot wait you're totally right
I remember being at your apartment and
I'd be like let's start the podcast and
you're like Esther like I'm like Esther
I need at least 45 minutes to get these
eyelashes on I think this is my dad's
fault I think my dad would like train me
that like being ready fast is like a
skit because you would always have to
wait for my mom and like he'd be annoyed
do you take less time than Dave yeah
Dave has to like unhook all this
he just wears it around the house
no that's like I feel like that's one of
my little mini skill sets I like to brag
about is like I can be ready in five
minutes to go and do anything yeah it's
so annoying though when you need ten
minutes is painful when Esther's ready
and you're not
just like that's the most I can do yeah
like I don't know what else like I can't
do eye makeup like that dude you're
weirdly skilled at it yeah I feel fast
yeah that's what never makes sense to me
about you it's like why are you good at
how are you good at growing I was a baby
[ __ ] okay so my mom did a different
thing where she tried to make me a boy
so then I tried being a boy to get her
attention and it actually didn't work
she traded me off the boys baseball team
I mean she really was like no I didn't
mean I like boy I like people that
aren't you Annie right right it just was
the opposite of you so then when when I
realized I wasn't gonna get her
attention that way I rebelled against it
and then I got like really girly and
very [ __ ] because I didn't have like a
mom who was like feminine to teach me
that you don't have to be like a [ __ ] to
be feminine you're just trying to get
that attention yeah like I didn't know
so I dressed like a baby [ __ ] but I was
always doing my makeup like
crazy amounts of makeup in high school
and stuff yeah you're very good at it
and it always is like weird to me like
aren't you supposed to be like an ugly
comedian like we're like no we don't do
that anymore yeah no I love I like it
I'm still doing it
[Music]
I have to say I can't believe we're
being sponsored by Sakara it's one of my
favorite hot girl Foods
um and I do think that like how you feel
starts with how you eat and when I eat
Sakara I know that I'm in a reset I'm
feeling my best I'm feeding my body all
of the best nutrition that it needs and
it's been figured out by someone else
someone else put in all that effort and
all the research and all the time and
all the ingredients and then I just get
to eat it and this is coming from the
girl who does nothing
zakara's plant Rich ready to eat meals
and functional Wellness Essentials
nourish your body with whole organic
ingredients that retrain your palate and
help you break up with your sweet tooth
for good oh she's breaking up with
everything sweet breaking up with my
sweet tooth too oh when you nourish your
body you can transform your life and
with sakara's delicious plant-rich meal
delivery program and functional Wellness
Essentials you can be in the driver's
seat of your own health and experience
true transformation I'm not gonna lie
their protein bars are pretty freaking
good no this is going to be great for
your breakup bud
you guys if you're going through a
breakup like me go get Sakara today
Sakara is a wellness company that's
anchored in food as medicine on a
mission to nourish your body through the
power of plants and I know that might
like it could sound cheesy but food is
medicine and like all of their
ingredients are so carefully selected to
have a function and a purpose in your
life makes your skin glow better you
know there's it makes you feel good your
digestion so again I always like it when
I do a little reset with Sakara I'll do
three days here five days there and then
I just feel my best I don't have to make
decisions about what I'm gonna make oh
will this have this ingredient whatever
no it's all there figured out for you
and it's not like you're just throwing
things together these are Chef crafted
breakfasts lunches the nurse and they
are so good you guys I definitely like
their metabolism bars like I don't
really understand why they're called
that I don't need to understand it they
just taste good and they make me feel
good and right now Sakara is offering
her listeners 20 off their first order
when they go to sakara.com trash Tuesday
or enter code trash Tuesday at checkout
that's Sakara
sakara.com trash Tuesday to get 20 off
your first order
sakara.com trash Tuesday
[Music]
we went shopping yesterday and I did the
if you go shopping with me like anyone
just like heads up this will happen I
will end up buying the exact same thing
as you at some point I brought it you
want to show yeah we both got the same
I'm gonna put it on
we should wear that for our stand-up
class this is the Boss part of Bonnie
boss
isn't it cool oh that is cool
pop the ass a little
I like it that is cute and you got it
too yeah wait what is the can we see
this video yeah this girl Julia yeah
your uh headphones are all underneath
thank you kind sir
that was like the most respect Carlson's
ever been treated with um no this
sweatshirt was respect
I'm bringing you the dirty one too
I could probably clean it too I feel
like you should get your OG back as well
yeah someone said you big time Me by not
giving it back to me listen I borrowed
okay I borrowed we went on a hike our
friend you know Brody Brody had just
died there was this really cool hoodie
of Brody so he lent me Brody's hoodie to
go on a hike and then I [ __ ] like
stained it and it was so shitty and so I
didn't give it back to him because I was
like I had plans when you have ADD there
I I have been cleaning that hoodie in my
head technically for three years
like it's in a pile of like fix this I I
have that pile too and I I don't want to
say I don't Big Time Carlos but in this
situation it was more of a small timing
myself
just like you know once you just [ __ ]
something upset about it's like too
embarrassing wait I like that instead of
big timing your small timing yourself I
don't know what that means but I it's I
feel like I do it my whole life I've
done it that's what you do when you like
you Dim Your Shine to make everyone else
feel it feels like stuff you put on your
fridge you know what I mean yeah don't
don't big time someone else you're just
small timing yourself yeah yes Bonnie's
acting like she doesn't send me
motivational quotes every day oh
it snows
a gatekeeper okay so vibing what what is
this this is Julia on tickets does she
have Jazz coming out of her mouth no
who needs to hear this but babbing works
babbing a hundred percent Works to do
what let's see the guy she works
I'm back and gave me this like what
because he wants you to not smell that
wait she he gave her perfect she gave
her perfume to cover up your [ __ ]
he's like you smell like ass she's
excited that the vabbing is working on
men well gynecologist does have a um
rebuttal to that okay okay
right forget the science for a second if
someone is only interested in you
because you smell like meow meow juice
do you really want anything to do with
that person if the rest of you as you
are is not enough to make them attracted
to you and is my friend Dr Jen Gunter
said there's no evidence that human
pheromones exist or that this works wow
there's evidence
so if you want to do this and it's not
hurting anybody else then feel free I'm
a big fan of bodily autonomy as you know
but obviously I don't think that you
need to do this
you know what I want to say about of
tick tock I want to see people's
bloopers how many times they've done yes
right well that's something
I called it fabbing again can we redo
this I keep saying fapping okay honestly
I feel like I want to turn this on you
Carlos like what is you're the guy here
like what is what do you think of that
he's repulsed by the vaginal smell like
is that because I'm I don't know wait
I'm gonna put I'm gonna put um Todd's
ball smell on me oh my God and see if
Carlos tries to lean in for a kiss like
I am so down to VAB I'm down with like
dirty stuff like that so I think I think
it could work for me
like I feel like the like the muskiness
of a woman like under like like armpit
smell like I'm into that so I think this
would actually like fool me but not all
women
no the only ones you're attracted to
only the ones the lizard brain is
attracted to yes yeah like the tricking
me and I wasn't into already and you put
like your [ __ ] juice all over you I'm
not gonna be like oh do you want a car
or something I mean I just like the idea
of like of like
like just doing a drive-by like a Hitler
stash a stash yeah you just go and you
just disappear I like that to find you
they're like
they're on Craigslist Miss connections
you wiped your [ __ ] juice on my lower
lip and I've been thinking about you
ever since I do love there's something
about the concept of like using your
body to gross out a guy like I love a
good like dip it in and swipe it on them
just to be like but then but they like
it yeah some of them do but well that's
why they don't smell isn't that why they
steal underwear and smell it well guys
that don't that guys that do complain
about smell are so annoying it's the
most it's a getaway for me right 100
getaway I can't stand it I had a
boyfriend that was like I have an
amazing sense of smell and he was always
grossed out about have fun being single
for this yeah I know it's like and he
really will be I'm not kidding
I think it's a defense mechanism it has
to be
you're just gonna be grossed out by the
smell of yeah everyone around you yeah
um I have a question this is vaginal
thank you I feel like kalila would be
the one that would be able to answer
this so let me let me give it a shot
there was a time where I started eating
a lot of pastries
where my vagus or pastries pastries I
was just chowing down I was leaving I
was leaving a lot of strippers with just
bleeding nipples
ring the bell thank you I was just
eating those pepperonis they're pasties
it wasn't my fault that's how they stick
them on yeah
um but my underwear started to something
got acidic In my discharge and it
started bleaching my underwear yeah
whoa no bleaching my underwear
went through your system leaked out
bleached your underwear you never had
cleaner underwear than when you were in
there it was so clean but it
it would tear holes in it
that's so and then I stopped I was like
it has to be the pastries because I
wasn't eating that type of food and then
I stopped it when I in my underwear is
starter dough for sourdough have you
ever done that well yeah over the
pandemic we all had to bake a couple
loaves
fries up in an hour it was wonderful
that's what Esther's Bell is it means
the bread's ready I will say that
sometimes
oh I can't sometimes I swear it's gonna
sound like a lie but it you're like
sometimes my vagina smells so good that
animals come and start eating no
sometimes it smells like McDonald's
french fries I'm it I know that seems so
specific and weird and that's from
you're touching it and then smelling it
that's like or like when you go to the
bathroom like whoa literally I'll get a
whiff and I'll be like that's that
you don't believe me no I believe you
but I don't believe that there isn't
like a french fries involved
I believe there's I believe you but you
believe in the science backing yeah it's
like I believe that you actually have
french fries inside you so and uh
an acidic vaginal environment is
protective actually it's a good thing it
creates a barrier that prevents
unhealthy bacteria and yeast from
multiplying too quickly and causing so
what is this but where does it come from
why did this happen it's probably
something in the pastry that was
creating bacteria in there and then it
turns it was burning the holes in my
underwear yeah so these are healthy
foods for it and none of these are
pastries cranberries fruits garlic
things like that you ate an unhealthy
food and your [ __ ] protected your body
garlic good for your body
and so bad I feel like when Carlos just
said it made no sense I just talked over
it I stopped listening to him when
Carlos tries to get all like I'll tell
you how it is it's because it requires
like four seconds of effort and this is
the easiest job in the world just go
back to talking about your [ __ ]
your job is easy we know Carlos
you're saying your job's easy
give me wait where is this good on the
pH scale or
he doesn't know they're not vegan I'm
gonna push it up my vagina anyway I
don't know I know very valuable
[Music]
s your period I don't care I just
pretend I'm killing her and uh I might
be telling you wrong but it's a very
funny joke and
um
I mean I have a better version of that
joke in myself anyway it doesn't matter
it was Whitney being like Rich was just
immediate like melting like Whitney
never tells us when she likes our joke
she just starts doing them and then I'm
like I guess she liked it
joking she doesn't Bonnie you're
disappointed in the amount of jokes I
told him this podcast no why okay I was
just curious too many
I think it's too many they want you to
be real Annie I um
okay self tips okay so I'm gonna start
doing this and it's
it's gonna be difficult in the beginning
but I am going to do the looking in the
mirror for one full minute
three times falling in love with
yourself I love myself I love myself or
I love you you have to set an alarm and
do it for one full minute and if you
don't feel love for yourself you have to
think of something you love like you
would have to think of donut or whatever
or donuts and
just pick a donut her dog's name's
Donuts also she's like I like sugar yeah
not anymore I still like it I I still
eat it but I eat I try to eat less why
does it sound like you're eating donut
anyway okay
so you think about something you love
while you're saying it so then the
feeling of actual love is in your body
while you're looking at yourself and
saying you love yourself so you have to
say it over and over you can say I love
myself or I love you into the mirror oh
that's one minute isn't it there's a
book called love yourself like you love
yourself like like your life depends on
it yeah yeah and it's good and I can
give you the gist I mean because there's
a whole nother part that I didn't do
which I don't know if you need to do but
he had to like write a love letter to
himself and burn it or something I'm
like I don't think you have to do that
no but you can I never understood and
the burning of things unless you're
scared of fun that's true let
me just like toss it away or probably
into the ocean yeah well that's
littering but that's better who cares
you're really vegan yeah so okay Annie
was making fun of me I was strictly
vegan for three years and then
I got pregnant
had a miscarriage obviously
um because you're eating meat no no I
so I when I was pregnant I had all these
for like I had the cravings and stuff
and so I completely stopped being vegan
and then since then I've just been like
not vegan yeah I wasn't vegan when I was
pregnant either okay
I was vegetarian then I went back to
meat then I went back to vegetarian then
was your body like craving meat when you
were pregnant
it was literally craving everything I
had a [ __ ] cookie the size of my head
every single day when I was pregnant I
mean I would just like one time I
dunking donuts they didn't have them and
I was like flipping out I was like what
happened it's gonna come in me
[Laughter]
Carlos I think I texted you a tick tock
hold on this is this Jeff
yeah want to know what healthy
self-esteem is it's when you see
yourself as no better or no worse than
anyone else unhealthy self-esteem is
when you see yourself as worse than
everyone else which manifests shame and
inferiority or when you think you're
better than everyone else which
manifests grandiosity and superiority
now you know I mean my dad has to say
that look at him I feel like we have
I'm better I'm not
about that guy I'm not therapy Jeff he's
like I'm sorry and I mean not really I
play in my head you want to know about
self-esteem
oh my God I [ __ ] show the bullies my
my therapy Jeff account oh my God Jeff
is in therapy no no no he's a therapist
he's amazing he's just a guy who went he
went into therapy because he was so look
at how old I was bullied every day of my
life growing up now I have a healthy
self-esteem
you got better than anyone those bullies
had bad self-esteems like it's a great
self-esteem
knowing I'm better than that guy I feel
wonderful oh my God I literally
literally I'm like Dave it's therapy
Jeff come look oh my god do you feel a
little low today
back in the day when I got my ears
pinned
um
people told me to fix my teeth I I
didn't do it I said no I I said I just
comb the hair over the bald spot
some people don't like short men I don't
think you can tell while I'm sitting
someone who doesn't like a sport guy
the Bell is there for Rings no reason
look at
it on my out of breath guys you guys
have to stop he's so nice is Dave
jealous Dave is Dave stop looking at
Jeff I find making fun of people
honestly a form of affection that's like
you know I'm listening to him I'm paying
attention to him I see him yeah me and
Annie must be really hot and heavy we
are a thing
yeah why is it that you like being made
fun of but Jeff can't be made fun of
well Jeff didn't ask for this yes he did
he put himself oh no you he didn't go to
a speech therapist and then he put
himself on camera when you were when you
were in in the universe as stars
deciding whether you were to come to
Earth you and Jeff got together and
you're like let's have big ears and be
short stop it let's see if we can do it
who can still make it who can still make
it let's see if we can get through life
being shorter than every other person on
Earth why do you guys think he's short I
mean I can tell by the way his shoulders
are yeah
last night there was a guy in the front
row on a date with a girl and he was
half of her size and it took me my I
like
the amount of strength it took me to not
make fun of his height is how I have to
talk about it right now do you know what
I mean like I did put so much effort
into it that I have to mention it here
to get praised right I was like
your glasses I just didn't want to make
fun of him for when he always gets made
fun of oh my God what about was odd
stage and
this was in Austin I don't know if you
saw this show but um so I asked this
couple's a question I don't know what it
was and she I could tell the way she
leaned forward and immediately answered
I go let let him answer let him answer
he'll let that let the man have a moment
you know and then he was I was like what
do you do and he was like I I I I I I
like he was I mean I'm not doing a good
stutter but he was like and then I
looked at her and she goes
and then I just had to like wait it out
and I was like it took forever and I was
like oh my God how do I get out of this
I don't know and then someone finished
his sentence for him over you know some
other guy yelled it out and then I was
like oh thank you and then I dealt with
the guy who yelled instead of you know
somebody was and that guy was a guy who
had a he kept like yelling out I don't
know if you went to him first but he had
a um was this last night no no
this was this was the set I cried at so
he goes
he goes well she goes what are you doing
she goes I own a water company yeah yeah
right and she goes you own a water
company and he goes yeah but it's like
special and she's like what's special
about it and he's like oh well it's like
weed wait cannabis and fish it's
cannabis and food water infused water I
like what I'm hearing right and Bonnie
goes well why would you want
cannabis and oh he's gonna say it helps
you sleep it helps you sleep
and I was like why would you want to
drink yeah that's what I like to do
before I go to sleep is drink a full
thing of water yeah and then and so
everyone's laughing it's like perfect
and then she goes well what's the name
of the company and it was like something
like named after it was something named
after a DJ and he goes I named it after
a DJ and she goes and for these Reasons
I'm out that's amazing it was so it was
like the best crop book I've ever seen
it is weird that being a DJ is like
almost like the Guy Fieri of occupations
like it's just embarrassing but now it's
kind of not because they're the ones
that are literally making they're making
so much 20 million dollars how because
people need music people like to dance
people don't know how to put together a
list somebody's never done Molly let's
just say kalila right now is learning
why DJs make money in her little k-hole
halfway through one song you got to
bring in another song it's not as easy
as you think you know yeah sometimes
it's like listen you have to be like
what's going to go on after this you
know what they do they go one two three
one two three one it's like really
impressive for someone with no rhythm
that's
you could be a DJ what do you think
about DJs do you think it's hard no it's
not hard okay that's yeah you probably
just need a Macbook right yeah why are
you so mad I'm not mad you're projecting
Carlos I think you're mad at me today oh
do you really feel like I'm mad at you
because you're projecting because I have
nothing but love right now let me tell
you when I've been mad at you I'm
certainly I've been mad at you
what
we don't I don't know that I've been mad
at you I'm thinking about it I'm trying
to think about it we've never gotten in
a huge fight before I've Never Been
Enough by the way I was going through
old photos today and there are some
photos of us three on a walk and we are
so
ugly
we were ugly no I remember Carlos taking
pictures of us eating Slurpees and it
was like we look like we eat Slurpees
like I'm gonna be like wow I just want
to tell the young people out there that
if you think you're not good looking it
gets better okay because these the three
of us
I can't speak for you I don't know what
you look like no we saw the picture on
her [ __ ] we were sorry
I don't think you're hearing how ugly
all three of us were one of my favorite
Instagram posts was of my own
um
I know I was like I don't want it to
sound like I'm giving a compliment to
him about myself not that I'm better
than you guys but I am better than Jeff
no Annie I'm better than Jeff I'm better
than Jeff I have a psychology degree I
have a psychology degree no you don't
yes that's not that's not healthy
self-esteem uh I'll tell you what's
healthier right if you think you're
better than other people that's not
healthy it's not I gotta hear him again
Kanye says that yeah or yay sorry
that's so annoying to make people say
yay yeah I don't want to say yay right
now look at Carlos self-esteem involves
self-love I would do anything for Jeff's
hair Carlos I bought you Jeff's hair and
you [ __ ] peeled it off your head wait
who's this
sentence I bought you Jeff's hair said
in an angry job I'm actually this is our
first fight
no honestly Carlos you blew it with the
toupee
the second day you're wearing it was so
good though it was he was I got him a
toupee for our live show Hollywood grade
it was like I mean I dropped cash I
dropped cash
and I wish the hairdresser had like
faded it into your hair better but it
was just it was just atop his head I got
a joke one that looked like a merkin
like it was like just like really like
like curl like Fred or uh true frog then
I was not gonna say Jewish but yes it
was very Jewish and um as a joke and I
look over and the professional
hairdresser was putting that one on his
head like she had decided that matched
at the best
but the second day he was wearing it was
funny when he had like his hat on
because Jeff still has hair on top of
his head
I'm like trying to do that
it's going great
if you believe try hypnosis yeah
hypnosis I wonder if you can make your
hair grow back with hypnosis
probably anything is possible No Limits
Annie Get rid of the blocks you're
you're balding because you believe
you're balding okay I'm gonna do
hypnosis with you this is giving me the
Vibes of when Kanye said slavery is a
choice like this is not good let's not
bring up his worst hits slavery is a
choice and he said being gay was a
choice earlier no I didn't well you told
me to choose to be gay I mean you can
still choose to be gay yeah I guess
that's true you don't you know it you
know it doesn't have to work like that
you can be born gay but you can also
choose to be gay yep look at that
somebody were not fighting you didn't
have to roll your eyes at me
I let you squirt oat milk calm in my
face earlier why did you call it oatmeal
come
said that word except
all right this show's over I want to do
more no okay she's got it I want to do
how many more like things could you have
I thought you hated men
we'll see you guys next week for a brand
new episode
thank you
foreign
[Music]